we're central watch we handle the finest
brands the vintage and new watches we
have the best equipment we're now the
behind the scenes place for a lot of
major watch companies watches today have
become especially on the second-hand
market it's a billion-dollar industry
building a portfolio of watches is
almost the same as doing it with stocks
and bonds
this watch is hot because it's the
original work of the Breitling this was
originally designed as a pilot's watch
it's something that could shoot up once
they start to really disappear from the
market you could see a really nice rate
of return on them this watch would be
your Apple stock it's been just
continuously go up you can sleep safe at
night
knowing that this is one of the things
locked up in your vault that is going to
grow in value no matter what the omega
brand is your IBM of stocks it's a
company that's been growing over the
years you don't see a lot of these in
the stainless steel cases I wouldn't be
surprised in 10 years if this was at
$8,500 watch we saved the best for last
this is the bond that you hold forever
and just see growth even during the
recession time Patek was the one brand
that you did not really see fall apart
it's a little bit more money to get into
but the bigger investment brings the
bigger return
you